but Patrick asks what did you learn
selling baseball cards that I could
apply to selling vegetables at my first
farmers market coming up Patrick this is
amazing watch their eyes that's what I
learned in baseball cards as you guys
now know or if you don't know if you go
to my website right now link it right
here you got a lot of work to do this
coming out next week
I date trade attention and build
businesses when you day trade attention
eyes and ears are very important what I
learned and this is by the way this is a
stereo I would literally be on a
baseball card show and I'm gonna I'm
gonna paint it for you because it's
really important I would literally like
I would get there at 6:00 7:00 a.m. the
show would open at 9:00 7:00 8:00 a.m.
and I would have my table and I would
sit there for hours
Garrett pay attention and I would sit
there for hours and I would do this and
then this and then this and I would look
and I come around and I'll never forget
this I always come around I try to
understand it from that perspective I
would pay attention to what the other
dealers were doing and so I'd be like
okay he has a lot of boxes here so like
if I go white space here I gave a lot
I'm a kid I'm 13 I'm 14 and I'm thinking
about how would you walk through this
small and if you just saw that guy's
table what does my table have to do so
that you're not you know there's 80
tables here what would you have to see
there that would then make this stand
out in the context of that and that and
then what could I do and if you look at
this table this is the big punch line
right the orange thing so let's call
that the ken griffey jr. rookie card do
I put in the middle but then it's hidden
by all the other cards so I put a top
left corner and it's funny even as a kid
and this is how I understand websites
I understood that's how people read so I
would put my flashiest hardest core
hottest items in the top left corner
because I understood that's how the I
would look at it be like whoa there's
stuff here you know to me that's a
really interesting insight to how I roll
it's how I think about the first five
seconds of this video when you watch it
it's how I think about my tweets it's
like it's how I think about my opening
line when I give a keynote speech that
all of you have seen in the cliche how
many people know who I am who don't know
who I am everybody raises their hands oh
[ __ ] that hurts ha ha ha humility
because I'm about to deploy a lot of ego
so you know for all my yeah I'm quite
calculated and that's how I
about it and so what I would tell you
Patrick is it Patrick pay attention to
the eyes understand the context think
about the parking-lot flow of the
vegetable market and think about what
most people walk through and how do you
have and do you have a vegetable that
nobody else has do you have a better
price on something that nobody else has
understand what they just saw understand
where they're going where's the
bathrooms in the porta-potties where's
the honey lady like there's the sausage
guy like I'm the only person that sells
pickles in this entire a row think think
think and then when you sit down and
watch in your first table just watch
that's all I did I was like a weird I
look like a weird dude probably because
I would just watch and I would watch
like a goddamn hawk and I would just
watch and see their eyes and then adjust
and be like maybe that wasn't working
counterpunching their attention